social practices but it's
not man who takes to the sea it's the sea
that takes man
the sea and the ocean it's absolutely
powerful we navigate around the world with
energy observer using water
as  vector of energy
through hydrogen this model is an
energy model of the future respectful of
the environment i am a victorian from the
sahara i am a founding captain
of observer energy it was 30 years that
i originally sailed i  was a
merchant marine officer and at the same time an
offshore runner
so I did about ten major
transatlantic races in 2013
finding myself in the middle of the
Atlantic Ocean when I found myself in
total out of energy
it made me a lot  thinking
when we had around us a
multitude of its energy we
had wind and solar we were unable
to use them intelligently we
the idea of the concept of energy observer [Musi
] it's
seventy people for
design the beat  water around
forty engineers around thirty technicians
we use the various sources
of renewable energy that we store
in our batteries we
use wind power, tidal power and solar power to do this
by producing hydrogen from
sea water hydrogen is the most
resent element in the universe if we can use t
is water to trans
orm hydrogen to make the car move to he
t our house [Musi
] ener
gy observer it is  the very
first hydrogen ship around the world
the objective of this energy
observer ship is to go around the
world showing that these two
technologies are efficient and our
role is to find
innovative solutions for a  cleaner future
we will all be very happy with
this mission
[Music]